a tres días de reconocimiento el jueves
culminó el cara a cara entre siete
miembros de la cúpula de la ex guerrilla
farc y las víctimas de secuestros
perpetrados por la organización entre
1993 y 2012 con más de 21 mil 396
víctimas oficiales
[Música]
de desequilibrar y destruir la vida de
miles de niños que hacían parte de las
familias de los secuestrados por primera
vez los últimos dirigentes de la
guerrilla reconocieron públicamente ante
la jurisdicción especial para la paz la
política interna de la organización de
realizar secuestros en tres modalidades
para hacer intercambios de guerrilleros
presos para financiar su accionar armado
y para hacer control territorial el
responsable no es usted
los responsables fuimos nosotros
usted no es el criminal
los criminales fuimos nosotros entre
lágrimas las víctimas y sus familiares
relataron duros testimonios de las
violaciones vejaciones torturas trabajos
forzosos o desapariciones forzadas a las
que fueron sometidos al menos 148
personas secuestradas nunca volvieron a
sus casas con sus familias si bien la
mayoría de las víctimas presentes
hablaron de reconciliación exigen una
verdad integral a pesar del daño que me
hicieron
no los odio pero no lo puedo perdonar
hasta tanto no vea amigo
y saber a dónde le puedo ir a rezar un
padrenuestro el máximo dirigente de la
organización reconoció la práctica de
abusos sexuales durante los secuestros
también reconozco que a pesar de no
haber sido una política ni una práctica
direccionado por el secretariado o
hechos de violencia sexual en los
secuestros realizados dentro del
ejercicio el control del territorio se
trata de un acto simbólico pero también
político para que los desmovilizados
puedan acceder no sólo a las sanciones
de la justicia transicional sino al
perdón colectivo del pueblo colombiano
que todavía mira con incredulidad el
indulto de estos crímenes